what you told at the time of your
father's death I was told that your
father has had an accident
but that was the cover story told by the
CIA
my father Frank Olson was Army scientist
his research group had a relationship
with the CIA
they take him to New York Tuesday
morning early Saturday morning he's dead
what was my father doing what was the
CIA doing what happened there the
released CIA documents deal with a
project code-named MKULTRA there was in
it a story of a CIA experiment on an
unwitting civilian who was given LSD
you're the one on stage tonight dr.
Olson this has been the shift from
thinking that my father's death was a
mysterious suicide to knowing that it
was a CIA atrocity its 1975 there were a
lot of questions about the integrity of
US government
the government was so eager to shut this
down the tragedy that happened to the
family was very deep and very real
Eric's whole life has been sucked into
this terrible hole the see how he was
using LSD young people but I think the
real pad was something worse
he's a man that was profoundly
distressed about what he was learning
new information Frank Olsen a former CIA
scientist may have been murdered if you
thought somebody was detrimental you
would have no problem dealing with it
but then the question is who ordered
that the United States began to do
things which put its own democratic
institutions in great jeopardy and my
father was in the center of that
Frank was somebody who has secrets and
he was dangerous I can't tell you more
you
you